so thanks for
um coming and i'm really excited to be
here
um i hope that this talk will give you
an example of what people use node.js
for in the real world
um outside of just big companies and
web applications so uh
my project is called dats d-a-t
and this is kind of a state of the
project as of late 2014
and my name is max ogden and i'm based
in oakland california
the uh world capital of node.js and
tacos and bicycles
um i in my spare time i organized the
node school
event which the first one in uh there
was another school that just finished up
across the hallway
and note school is all the stuff that
the people who've been doing node for a
few years
know we put it into fun interactive
workshops so you can install them on the
command line and
learn node from really awesome tutorials
so check it out and i also really love
cats
this is a cat that i took a photo of
yesterday at a cat cafe in singapore
and cat cafes are the best thing ever
but okay so why i'm here is to talk
about my open source project
called dats and that is a tool for
sharing and collaborating on data and
those are two different
challenges sharing is just getting
access to the data
of either publishing or installing and
then collaborating is even more advanced
so
the life cycle of a data set as
different people use it trying to build
a tool set so that data can kind of live
and be contributed to by lots of people
it's very similar we're inspired to uh
on the project
by the git tool for source code but
data and source code are a lot different
so not all the same tools work in both
places
it's about a year olds or a little bit
over a year old and
we're not a startup a lot of people
think that we're a startup because we
have a logo but i think
open source projects and have logos too
we're a grant funded project
and everything we do is open source so
there's lots of ways to get involved and
we have lots of projects
we're grant funded by an organization in
the us that funds
um improvements to the way that science
is done
so most of our use cases are focused on
scientific use cases we work with a lot
of scientists
but i'm i don't have any college
experience i have a high school diploma
and i've been writing javascript for
like eight years so i'm not
a scientist i just pretend to be one and
i like to learn so it's really fun to
work with scientists
but this organization that funds us is
committed to making science more
reproducible and
easier to get involved with so a lot of
scientists will publish papers
and other scientists will say hey i
can't reproduce your results what gives
and that's a lot of people think that's
not science if you can't reproduce the
results in science it isn't science it's
only science that there's a test suite
basically
so we're trying to bring some of the
software development stuff
that people figured out for these large
scale software projects
trying to integrate it into the
scientific workflows a little bit we
specifically focus on data sets
um this is our team we have a really
awesome team um
a lot of people have day jobs and they
contribute to our project but we pay
everyone from our budget
and um everybody has a different
expertise so for instance
bruno here is a dna researcher and he
has a
server cluster at his university with
512 gigs of ram on it and he does dna
sequencing
so it's really fun to run that on a
machine with half of a terabyte of ram
and we just have a really cool
background uh lots of cool backgrounds
on the team
but what brings us all together is we
all work with node.js in various ways
there's lots of documentations
documentation that we've written for the
project one example is
we've been working on the project for a
year and it has a lot of different
components but
since when you make a big thing in dojs
you end up not just writing it all in
one repo you make a lot of modules
we have written or we use a lot of
modules and we took the time to document
all the modules we use so you can get an
example
of kind of when we're solving a problem
what tools from npm we use
you can find this just in the dat repo
on github
oh i should also mention the slides here
are available
i also tweeted them out but they're
available on
github pages there's a url here but um
just
either check my twitter or check out my
slides repo on github
if you want to see the links and stuff
so
to kind of set the stage for
understanding that
um there's already a concept most people
familiar with in coding is source
control
so has anyone done coding
and not used git or another source
control solution anybody remember
pre-git
before git took over the world yeah so
it was crazy
um so say say you find a cool project
and you want to fix something and send
the author a fix
um you have to get a zip file and maybe
it's on their personal page
maybe it's on sourceforge or
pre-sourceforge maybe it's on a mailing
list
you have to unpack it somewhere on your
machine and then you make your edit
and then you email the file back to the
author and hope that the author gets it
but you know for instance what happens
if you fix a bug and email your fix
and then at the same time someone else
fixes a bug and emails their fix
um all that work has to go through the
author like now it's the author the
maintainer's job
to fix all the conflicts but you can't
see that you
um maybe broke the other person's patch
and you can't take the initiative to fix
it yourself
so it ends up bottleneck there's a big
bottleneck on the maintainer
and if they're busy then the things
might not get fixed for a really long
time
so they ultimately have to make a new
zip file
of the project that might contain your
fix might not maybe they edit it a lot
there's not really a way to see
what they track changes with and then
they
redistribute the zip file um and it's
just a total mess like there's
there's no way to see history you can't
check out code to an old version
um and then git came along and basically
modernized it by creating a language
for collaboration so you instead of
unzipping and downloading you just clone
and then you can edit with your own
tools so you know git didn't reinvent
everything they didn't reinvent the text
editor
until this year but they then you add
files and you commit and you push and
then everything is tracked
um and the author um
if the author sees you send a patch and
see someone else send a patch
they can just um you know now that
github is here github came along
and you can actually see when you do
things like break the build break the
test suite
break someone else's patch and the
author can communicate with you
so it really it just opens up this whole
world of collaboration and a lot of us
are already familiar with this workflow
but you know when you want to get the
newest version you don't have to
download a new file you just get told
um so our kind of operating assumption
is that data sharing
is back in the days before git it's the
same
you know source code figured out first
about 10 years ago all these nice source
code tools that we all use modern
modern distributed source code started
hitting the world
and data sharing does not have any of
these tools
so what motivated me to get started on
the project was you know here's the
workflow we have now
email a csv file rounds you can do
things like put your sqlite
database into git and check it into
github but there's file size limits and
it doesn't support like real-time data
so our goal of the project at a high
level is we want to
take the transformational change that
git enabled without
literally copying all the stuff that get
did and just adapt it for data and try
to build a collaboration system for data
sets
so dat is a module on npm you can npm
install g
dat and it has a couple components one
is there's a command line tool
and another one is there's a web server
so you can host a data online so other
people can clone from you
so it's both a client and a server
depending on if you're consuming data or
distributing data
and here's an example workflow you might
um do a data init to create a new data
store in a repo just like get in it and
then you
just use any tool you want that produces
either json or csv data
and you can pipe it into a dat import
and then when you want to share your
data you can run that listen somewhere
and then
you can give that url for your server to
someone else and they can clone from you
so oh yeah so i have my um i i
got my genome sequenced by one of these
cloud services
and it's you know hundreds of thousands
of ac t's and g's
and so like for example i can uh take
this
file and let me bump up the zoom a
little bit so
if i um cap my genome
then you'll see it's uh you know a lot
of these
basic phenotypes and every gene has an
id and a position
and then it's just a bunch of raw
genetic data and they actually
distribute it
in a tsv format instead of csv format
so if i wanted to start revision
controlling myself
i can go and make a new folder called
genome and then go into genome and
init and it'll ask me a couple questions
like uh
my genetic data and publisher
is myself and now i have an empty dat
store what it actually does under the
hood is uh makes
a database inside of here and i'll talk
about that in a little bit
but now i can actually run my imports so
if i go to here and
so i'm going to use a csv parser to
parse the data into
json so now i've converted it from tsv
into json
and that means that i can just add dat
imports
json to the end and then it'll import
my data into the debt store and so it'll
start parsing the data and
so it's parsed you know 60 000 of my
genes and it's going to sit there and
import the data set until it finishes
importing but it usually takes
a little while so i will just cancel it
and so now i can cap myself
out well i guess it didn't commit any of
the changes but the idea is you know you
import data into that and then now you
can track the
um that's basically the import process
and once data is in that then you can
replicate it to other places
so you can also clone so uh if you have
a data set
url for someone else that's hosting dat
you can clone a data set down
and then once you have a data set that
you've cloned
if you want to get all the changes you
can just pull so
this simplifies a lot of the workflow
that you see in
data set consumption a lot of times when
you're working with data sets you'll
either get
you know an ftp server with like a csv
file and the csv might update every
night at midnight
but you have to download the csvs and
kind of dip them yourself and figure out
which data you have
already imported and it just becomes
like this much code that you have to
write every time
so we wanted to reduce the amount of
code down to just the datpoll commands
so you can just type that poll you get
the newest stuff without having to
re-download the entire thing
and we also support live pull which is
pretty pretty cool feature
um everything inside of dat uses node
and because we use node we can support
a lot of real time stuff so we
everything is stream
and that means that you can just have
your dat sitting there listening like
dropbox getting the latest data
as it as it exists on the server
and we also support large file
attachments so you can put movies or
photos or
you know treat that kind of like a file
system
and our backends is that we use a
database called leveldb
by default and level db's pretty cool
database you can
check it out it's written by google and
it's it's not really a database
in the traditional sense like mysql or
mongodb it's more like a database
library that you can use to build your
own database so it's just a c
plus library that does one small job
really well
and you can kind of build your database
on top of it and
we also um for storing bigger files that
belong on the file system and not inside
of a database
we have a thing called blob stores and
blob is just
a binary large object it's just a weird
programmer word for
basically an attachment and um we have
an api called the abstract blob store
that
anytime we want to write an adapter for
dat
that saves data somewhere on a file
system we can use this api
and this has like a little test suite
and so for instance if you wanted to
have a dat that uploads to s3 when you
upload a file into that
but you don't want to write any s3 code
you can just use the s3 blob store
if you want to have one that works with
dropbox you can use the dropbox blob
store
so it's kind of um it's a nice
abstraction layer around
file storage and one of the things that
we're motivated to do
is make it so if somebody publishes one
of these plugins
then other people can just use the
plugins instead of having to write their
custom code again
so we have you know things like store
the files on the local file system
on ftp we're trying to just make uh you
know what node.js is really good at is
just move data around and we want to
make this api this blob store api
something that has every popular file
storage backend supported by it
so you can just plug in the right thing
into that of where you want your files
to end up
and node will stream them from a to b
so some other stuff that we do um is
we generate a schema for you
automatically which can be annoying
sometimes we give you a free rest api
for your data so you don't have to build
your own
non-standard rest api for just letting
people download your data data
and everything in that is streaming
which means it supports arbitrarily
large data sets without crashing the
server so you can upload
terabytes of data and it doesn't crash
it just might take longer
so okay concrete example um so
we have the npm data set that we've
imported into debt because traditionally
you know cloning npm is um
really difficult and installing the
dependencies to run your own npm locally
is really difficult
so we've been experimenting with putting
npm into that so we can treat npm
as just a nice easy to use data set
so we have a data set up at npm.hub.org
data is just like kind of a test domain
that we've been playing with
and so the data set has
you know a little over a hundred
thousand rows one um row for every
module and npm but we also store
revisions of each so every time a
published
a module gets published we store a new
version in the old version
and then we have links to the actual
file so we just basically store a bunch
of json from npm
but then we also link to the actual
files themselves
so when you want to get the actual npm
stores everything
as tarballs so when you want to actually
get the tarball we have a link to the
tarball and
the link is in a format that that can
understand and translate
it'll go and fetch the tarball from npm
and download it for you
so what this means is you can take this
url and
if i go back up to my desktop i can say
that clone the url
and by default what it'll do is start
downloading all the data from npm both
the metadata which are the row data
as well as the tarball data and then i
get a full offline clone of the entire
npm registry
so this will take a long time because am
on conference wi-fi
and b but it is actually working and b
um the npm data set is uh
upwards of 100 gigabytes so this will
sit there overnight and it will fill up
your hard drive with all the npm data
but you know if you have 100 gigabytes
to spare you can use all you can
download all of npm onto your laptop so
you can have it offline
but i'm going to cancel that and then
start over so
if i delete the npm folder and then run
it again but this time add the
skim option let me make sure i'm
following yeah so
dash skim this means don't download the
files just download the metadata
it's a lot faster so you'll notice now
it's only downloading it's not
downloading any of the actual blobs it's
just
downloading the json data from npm which
means if
later you want to go and get one of the
files if i you know i'll kill this
go into there run that listen um oops
and then open up my localhost then i
have um you know the 845 rows that i
just pulled are now running in local
debt
and if i view one of these then this is
a link to one of those tar balls
but if i click it then only then will
that go and fetch the file
and then let me download it so i can
download the tarball kind of lazily
so you can either choose do you want all
the files up front
which is like you know slower to
download at first or do you want to get
the files later
and then you can download just the
metadata for a data set and this kind of
distinction is just really nice when
you're dealing with really big data sets
you can
kind of program more flexibly
so we can also do some cool stuff once
we have npm data
um like let's calculate you know if you
ever wondered how many gigabytes is npm
actually so we would have to basically
loop through every row loop for every
file on every
package and get the file size and then
just add it all and then
when we're done we can figure out what
the total size of all of npm is
so i just like a good cooking show i
have prepared
um a full copy
of i've cloned this this morning at the
breakfast place in the hotel i cloned
all of npm so
this one um if i open up this server
this one actually has uh all 113 000
modules that have been published to npm
but it's running locally so i can
access them offline and i have this
little file here
and basically what this does is
opens up the dat um in the current
directory and then
uh creates a dot read stream which
basically loops through every row and
all of that one at a time and for each
one i
just add the size of each file to a
a big summary byte size and
so you'll see if i run this um
then it'll just start streaming through
all the rows and dat and just
calculating the ultimate
file size and you know this takes a
minute to run because it has to move
through all of npm but
at the very end then you'll get the
final file size of all of npm
so that's just a pretty trivial example
of doing something with
dat stream but there's another cooler
one that i can do
oh yeah so this is the link to the
source code if you go to the slides and
um the idea with that is that you use uh
unix pipes so you can do
for instance that cat to cut out all the
rows and debt and pipe them into
whatever you want so
you don't have to write your tools in
node you can do anything that you can
write on the command line so you can
write stuff in python r
like any language that you can write a
command line api for you can use with
that
and you can also use docker if you don't
want to have your users
you know if you're like oh i wrote this
really cool python thing but it requires
a certain version of python and
you know here's like a 30 minute
instruction for how to actually get
everything compiled and by the way one
of the python modules uses c
plus so you have to install you know
xcode before you can compile it or
windows visual studio on windows
and it's just you know if you don't want
to have to have all that setup stuff
um we we really like docker as a way of
just you know you publish just a docker
container that has all your stuff
pre-compiled
and then the user just has to install
docker and then they can just run your
thing
they don't have to compile anything so
we're compatible with that too and you
can actually stream data into docker
so for instance you know npm
part of the metadata on npm is uh they
have
all the readmes actually in here um
so part of their uh one of the
attributes on their json is they have
like the full markdown
for the modules for from the readme in
the json
so um since we have all the readmes we
can do stuff
like um where is
yeah so so for instance here's a dot
query that you can do
so you can pass some arguments to that
cat so i'll get
all rows that are greater than or equal
to the word dat but only get five of
them
and um so that'll get the last five
modules
uh it's kind of hard to read because
it's a lot of data but you know i got
like there's a module that's tracking
ebola data in that
there's a module that is the actual dat
module will get
uh returned here so basically this just
gets the first five dat modules on npm
and then if i pipe them into we've
created this um
bulk markdown to png docker container so
what it does
is you pipe it some json data that has
markdown in it
and for each one that it gets it um
opens up that markdown
in a headless web browser and it takes a
screenshot of the rendered markdown
saves it as a png adds a png to a
tarball
and then streams the tarball data back
out to you so you can convert a bunch of
markdown
files into a tarball full of pngs
so if i run this really quick it takes a
second because it has to boot up you
know get the data out of the day
out of that boot up the docker container
but now i should have this png.tar file
that just got created
and if i extract that then i get these
pngs of the five models that
it just streamed in so you know this is
the kind of stuff that
um i just did it in one command
you know all you have to do is clone npm
that's one command and then
pipe the data into the data processing
pipeline
and this is something that people in
science well all programmers do it but
people in science specifically do it and
they have such crazy dependency issues
so um we're trying to just make this
stuff as easy as possible and use the
most modern tools possible so that
instead of rewriting you know i could do
this in bash or i could do this in node
but
we really like command line we really
really like things that are easy to
install
so that's kind of our motivating um
that's our motivation
so another thing that we built is um
this thing called git dat
and um this is kind of
inspired by node school so for instance
um
let me make sure i'm still connected
here yeah so this is actually just
available
on online it's just called get that but
it's hosted on github pages and what we
are what you're looking at here
is an environment for learning that
interactively so when you load this page
it actually we're running a server on
the back end
that as a new user connects it creates
them a new virtual
ubuntu machine we have a template docker
container
that we can boot up a new instance of
the container it has dat pre-installed
it has node pre-installed
and so this user gets their own
custom docker container here so for
instance this is the id for this
container
and this is all just running client side
but we emulate actually a terminal
we connect to the actual terminal
session on the new server over a
websocket
so i'm actually logged in as root to a
real ubuntu machine but it's running
sandbox so
um you know i can't like delete the
machine or anything i can just mess with
my little sandbox
so for instance i can type here um you
know
i could create a new file i could say
touchfu.txt
and then down here we actually wrote a
little text editor so you can open up
foo.txt and you can type into it like hi
and then now if i cat food.txt then you
know it prints out high
so we've connected the the server that
you're an actual ubuntu server
on the backend with a little terminal so
you can run commands
and also expose the file system to the
browser so you can edit it right in the
browser as a kind of text editor i can
also do stuff like npm install
um like i have a module called cat
picture you can npm install stuff
and as npm is working um you know it's
going and fetching the module from npm
and you'll see
you'll see the actual folders get
created here as it downloads the
stuff so now i have an actual little
node models folder i can go in and view
the module that i
i just required i can edit its source
code in here and you know so you have
like a full little development
environment
it also comes with that pre-loaded so
you can actually host
um a little server in here so uh
and just send this link to somebody and
they can open up your server
so you should try this workshop workshop
out it's free it's
um it's just called get that i think if
you actually just go to the dat readme
um you can get a link to this and
there's on this pane over here we have
the actual tutorial
and it gives you instructions on how to
play with different parts of dat
and it gets kind of more difficult as it
goes along
so this is something that we just
recently shipped and
we've been really excited about because
it kind of just makes the barrier
venture as low as possible
um so i want to talk about one of our
use cases just to give you an example of
like you know
okay so there's these cool tools but
what actually is the data that we're
using
um so there's these this project called
trillion
and they what they do is they are a
bunch of astronomers
and they have you know these big
astronomy telescopes that are at
universities
and they do these scans of the universal
they'll like take a picture and then
move a little bit take another picture
move it a little bit
and it takes some years to do and but
what they what they end up with
is all this imagery of every star that's
visible in the whole sky
some of them aren't the entire sky some
of them are just parts of the sky but
it's a lot of data and it's a lot of
stars and then what they do is they run
an algorithm over
all the images and they detect all the
stars and the positions of the stars in
the sky
how big they are you know what
frequencies of light they were able to
detect and they get all this metadata
about every star so then you get text to
data
like um basically a big csv
um but there are huge files and they're
in an astronomy format
that is like kind of just a specialized
format that only astronomers use
so even if other astronomers want to use
it they might not be familiar with the
weird format that the other astronomers
use
and also it's just um to download like
one star in the sky you might have to
download
a 10 gigabyte chunk of this guy because
they only distribute them in these big
files there's no real database they're
using
an example of the scale of the data i
mean the universe is a very big place
um there so for just one of these data
sets
from one researcher they produced after
compression
a terabyte of csvs because it's um 600
million stars that they detected in
their scan
and then for each star there's 30
different attributes that they recorded
so 30 different numbers that they wrote
down um
they extracted from their telescope data
and that ends up being
uh or sorry not 30 300 columns um so
it's a cs
imagine opening a csv in excel and it
has 300 columns and 600 million rows so
that's the data set that we're working
with
and that data was actually extracted
from the raw imagery and they sometimes
want the raw imagery too
and that's 40 terabytes of just pictures
so what they really want to do this is
what they release it as now it's just a
html table that links to all these you
know nine gigabyte csv
files and basically what this is saying
uh this these numbers here in the deck
range covered
is it's saying there's 15 million stars
in this file
and it's this region of the sky so if
you want to download just one star
you can't just download that one star
you have to download the other 15
million stars next to it
before you can extract the one star um
and the download takes overnight and
it's just you know super
super painful you can't really do a
quick experiment with this kind of data
so i built this little tool recently
i've been getting into astronomy now
because of this project
just to kind of visually explain so this
is a bounding box in the sky
and this is using the google sky tiles
it's basically google maps but they
um they use astronomy data and
um what we really want what a lot of
these astronomers want is they want to
take this bounding box
and they want to say you know i want
this part of the sky so i want
the rectangle to be you know the center
of this galaxy
and i can't click the thing so they want
to basically
like pick out a range of the sky and
then say
um save and then zoom in on that
and then they get this little coordinate
these coordinates down here
and they want to plug these coordinates
which represents this rectangle
into a database and basically just
download that rectangle
without you know and the rectangles that
they get with the csv files are really
big
and if they just want one star they'll
make a really tiny rectangle and they
just want to say
just download the data from just this
area but they can't do that easily
so what we did is we figured out a way
to import it into dat
there's these things called geohashes
which are pretty cool and geohashes take
like a
x and a y coordinate or like a latitude
longitude um
they actually use a thing very similar
to allow to choose longitude in space
but it's called right ascension and
declination
but it's basically x and y coordinate
just like a two dimensional plot
and it combines for you know maybe your
x is one and your y is one you can take
that point one comma one
and you can turn it into this address um
and the address is just like a text
address
and really what it means is you know e
would be like a big rectangle over one
half of the sky
eb would be all of e but then b is like
another smaller rectangle inside of e
the more letters you have the more
zoomed in it is it's kind of like google
maps
zoom levels um so what we can do is um
you know we found out a pretty simple
way to index it all in that
and you can actually build a query
system on top of it where you take that
rectangle that you get from the web app
and um that actually creates so you know
if i wanted to
query the the region from 305 to 306 and
from negative 1.27 to positive to
negative 1.26
um you know rectangle um then i can
query it
out of that by just creating all these
um
query query ranges so basically you know
it gets everything from
gzz uh p
p g p g p y to p g p g z
um you know so it basically creates it
figures out where all the rectangles and
use the query are and then it goes and
queries them from the database
so this is just meant to show that um if
you can find out a cool way of indexing
your data you know coming up with the
primary key for your data
importing it to dat you can usually do
some pretty cool stuff to query it
but one big caveat with that is and it's
also because of
level db which we use level db isn't you
know sql it doesn't have sql in it
so if you really want to do crazy
queries like show me
all restaurants that are in singapore
that are open from five to six that have
caps in them
um which is query that i wanted to do
yesterday you can't really do those kind
of complicated queries you can't do
joins um so if you get beyond anything
like the level of complexity here um
then
you shouldn't really put your database
into debt and that's the end of the road
really what that does for you is lets
you just stream the data from
the remote source into your machine and
then keep streaming it into other places
so one of the use cases we're also
pushing towards
is you might have a redis database or a
postgres database
and whereas you can't necessarily take
postgres and just tell it
you know stream data from the server
down and just have a live copy of the
data
because postgres doesn't have stuff to
copy you know all the stuff that that
has
you can just put it into that first and
then have that put it into postgres for
you
so that's a thing that we're building
tools out for as well
um and then another use case of ours is
you know take the universe and zoom in
all the way down to
the atomic level we're doing a project
called bionode which is a
dna researcher who is wrapping all these
hard to use bioinformatics tools and
putting them on
npm so bio bio node is really cool
because
you get all the advantages of dependency
management with npm so you can just npm
install stuff
but you don't necessarily have to you
know compile c to get the stuff to work
um it can just be made a lot more easy
and then you can also use node to stream
the data between these tools
and just use them on the command line so
part of this project is to figure out
how to build really complicated data
pipelines
and to do the dependency management for
those pipelines and to make sure
everything streams between everything
because with dna you need to download
the dna and that's what that does is go
and get the data from wherever it is
it's usually on these big government
servers or on university servers
you want to stream it down and then you
want to pipe it into your actual
analysis pipeline and that could be
composed of a python script an r script
a c
script a whole bunch of stuff and you
want to make sure the data flows into
all of them efficiently
so for instance this is a docker file
this is what a dockerfile looks like
and this dockerfile actually installs
this thing called samtools and samtools
is a very popular
genetic sequencing command line tool
written in c plus notoriously hard to
install
so what we've done is created a script
that installs it and then puts it in a
docker container
so you can just use the docker container
without actually having to compile and
learn all this stuff
if you're like a sysadmin it's not that
big of a deal but most users aren't
um so they they don't want to know how
to
debug their path and stuff like that um
and then this is uh what samtools looks
like it's actually
it's a pretty cool app because it shows
you genetic information
like a c t's and g's but on the command
line
it's kind of a fun little thing but um
the command we're running is we're
actually
doing docker run with our samtools
container and then just piping the data
into it
from dat so the whole idea with
our use of docker is um you know
get it working on the author's machine
and then when you publish it
another scientist can use it and know
it's the same code that you ran so it's
it's towards the goal of reproducibility
um
and we've also been experimenting with
some other approaches these are
definitely more experimental
but um you know bash scripts are awesome
except when the windows user wants to
use them
um or you know when people write bash
that gets out of control so we've been
playing around with this thing called
gasket
and this is what gasket syntax looks
like it's just json and you put all the
commands you want to pipe together into
json
and then you can use gasket which uses
basically it's just a node.js program
that will run your pipeline for you
and one thing that bash can't really do
that well
is an operation where maybe you want to
download something
spawn 50 processes you know parallel
process them
and then when they're all done aggregate
all the results and then do something
else with that
you really kind of have to write a
node.js script or some other kind of
dynamic programming language script to
do that kind of stuff
but we're trying to make it easy so you
can still have like a configuration
language for doing it
so this is a few pipelines with gasket
where you can do stuff like
import some data into that from a
bioinformatics server and then actually
do a bunch of metadata
analysis on it download a bunch of data
sets and then actually sequence the data
which is this bros wheeler alignment
thing which is a dna sequencing thing
so it's you know wrapping all these
tools in just an easy to read config
language
but even this isn't the level of uh
easiness that we want because you know
you still have to use json and if you
forget a comma then it'll blow up
if you use single quotes so we've even
been playing with this thing called that
script
which is actually vaporware right now
we're just designing it so it's not
implemented
but um it's kind of like a pipeline
config language
so this is kind of what that script
looks like so it just kind of looks like
a bash script
but you can say okay here's my pipeline
called reads and it wants to be three
these three commands and you can do
stuff like say
run this one and then fork this one so
you know
run this command and then for every
piece of output from the run command
then fork it into four separate
pipelines so pipe each piece of data
into these four
and then pipe all the output of that
into a dat
and or for instance you know you can get
more complicated and do
pipes into other pipes and it's kind of
just like a high level expressive
language
for complicated data flow scenarios but
a lot of scientists need this kind of
stuff
so um the future of the project
this has all been stuff that's
implemented so far except for that last
slide but kind of where we're headed in
the future
let me make sure that i didn't forget
yeah okay cool um is we want to have
uh the collaboration stuff that i
mentioned at the beginning we're still
building that stuff out
so for inst for instance in git you have
two different branches like we just have
one branch right now it's just
hard-coded there's only one branch of
the data
and so we want to be able to have
multiple branches so you can
have kind of version a of the data you
can have version b you can send somebody
your branch and they can
have a diffing tool that views the
differences between the data on the two
branches
this checkout is actually a huge one you
know imagine you publish a scientific
paper or you
publish a script a bash script that has
to download data from dat
if you just say checkout or if you just
say clone
you'll get the latest copy of the data
so if on a monday you
do a dac clone it'll get the data as it
was on monday but then if somebody runs
the same dac clone on friday
there might be a whole bunch of new data
from that week so we're adding a feature
called checkout where you'll get
basically a commit hash
and you can actually check out a copy of
the data set at a specific version in
time
deterministically so for reproducibility
this is huge
so basically a scientist could say
here's not only the data set command
to download the data set but here's the
exact version of the data set that i use
so you can totally reproduce all my
results and then
we also are really interested in live
replication between multiple people
because data is all streaming and in
real time you can start doing really
cool use cases where for instance
you know if the government publishes a
data set to one of its servers then you
can download it to your dat server and
import it into that
and then somebody might whenever you
update your data
like stream it into their server that
combines it with some other data set
and then somebody can stream that down
to their laptop so you can start
building these really cool
server to server pipelines and i
mentioned the synchronization
databases use case for instance you know
when data arrives on your laptop
automatically put it into my postgres
table under these columns
kind of automated data set sync for
databases
and then the most exciting one at the
very bottom in my opinion
is we're building a data set registry so
carissa who's on our team
is building basically uh
imagine npm but instead of node.js
modules we're
going to be able to let people publish
data sets so that's coming you know
hopefully end of the year the first
alpha of that
so that it's really easy to find data
sets and just get the datclone command
to clone them
um so our project like i mentioned is
fully open source
we're really active on freenode and i
really like this app called irc cloud
that's free to try out or five bucks a
month if you want to have it keep you
logged in all the time
they have a really nice mobile app
shameless plug i don't know the people
that run it but
the dot irc channel is where we do most
of our development and linking to
modules and talking about stuff
and then there's also uh
the dat repo has a lot of docs and goods
getting started tutorials on it
so um thank you very much
thanks max from astronomy to ebola to
human genome wow i'm sure we can get a
couple of questions on open data
science sets all right um
hey this looks amazing i'm really
excited about using it um at the
beginning of the talk you mentioned that
you
are not personally a scientist but i was
just wondering if you've engaged with
the computer science
community um of course there's a lot of
conferences specifically just devoted to
database design and development and how
they might view this work
oh good question um so yeah our outreach
strategy
is um not just go to javascript
conferences um everything is written in
node and it's all javascript but we like
to so we like to be um
well basically we're getting paid to
work with scientists so
even though it's a lot of fun to write
node.js not a lot of scientists right
node.js
so we've been going to a lot of uh
bioinformatics meetups
um database meetups we haven't gone to
or like conferences
we haven't gotten to as many of them but
our outreach strategy is basically
you know make something that developers
like to use but also make something that
scientists can use at the same time so
it's kind of
two goals that are different but i think
that we can achieve
both of them um but in terms of the
actual data model we've been getting
um some really cool contributions from
people on figuring out better data
structures you know all sorts of
distributed system stuff
um one thing that that doesn't do is
kind of multi-server data sets so
it all kind of assumes right now it's
still at an alpha stage
i should have mentioned we're not 1.0
yet but we're
uh all of our data sets assume you can
track them on one machine and there's
this whole field of distributed
computing and distributing computation
computation that you know maybe in a
year or two we'll be able to
devote the right amount of time to but i
mean though one thing i've learned about
this project so far is that it touches
on almost every field of computer
science it seems like because we throw
all the science stuff in
and all the database stuff and it's just
a very ambitious broad project so
we've been trying to start with baby
steps so far
yeah hey max thanks for the talk um you
just touched on something that i wanted
to ask about which is
it seems like some of this data
processing stuff would dovetail really
nicely with big data and hadoop
or that whole ecosystem do you see any
future connecting with that stuff or are
there other tools that do similar things
but on a more distributed scale how are
things related
good question um so i would say the way
our project fits in with like the
quote-unquote big data stuff
um is we're very community driven and
open source friendly we
really want to keep the barrier of entry
really low and the value i see in dat
is making these systems that are
designed by different organizations be
able to talk to each other through our
use of like plugins and modules so for
instance if you have like a hadoop
analysis cluster and then you have you
know some data source like you want to
import
for instance all this astronomy data you
would use that to hook up
the raw data into your hadoop cluster so
we actually have a thing called
our module wish list and
it is on this discussion um we have a
repo that's just basically
like our discussion board and um our
wish list we've been putting together
is basically everything that we want
people to write in terms of adapters
and we have the ones that we've already
written and then we have all these ones
that
are up for grabs and hadoop was one of
the first ones that people added here
so you know this is kind of the vision
for dat you know we're still alpha but
we want to
you know maybe in a year's time be able
to take any of these services and make
them sync to each other
so you can not you can stop writing
custom scripts that
is like a couchdb to my sequel importer
that only works between those two things
and you can instead just use that to
talk
between any of these so we can achieve a
really cool kind of network effect
um so i think you know you you're doing
your analysis on these hadoop clusters
but how do you get your data into them
that's really where that comes in
awesome that was
a lot of inspiring uh note on big data
huge data
so thank you max maybe we can catch hold
of him at the breaks
i'm sure all of us have more questions
to max thank you
you